and for the marlins
it is jesus louisardo acquired from the
oakland a's
last week at the deadline got uh a big
time arm obviously the numbers this year
not where he'd like
back to the mound luzardo fields throws
to first and there's one away
now number one job well done getting off
the mound two and two to the big burly
mets first baseman alonzo swings and
misses at a change-up there's two outs
the ground ball to first aguilar takes
it himself and it's a one two three
first first inning for jesus louisardo
mcgill his last start against atlanta
went five and a third only gave up an
earned run that's kind of been
the way mcgill has operated so far and
against his slider
four for 33 opposing hitters this year
this is a great count right here
hopefully miguel they tried to go in 3
or 2-0 and the pitch is grounded through
the right side and the base hit
drury picks it up in right field
chisholm's flying around second base
runners
on the corners with nobody out for the
marlins here in the first inning
first and third nobody out he's zeus
aguilar up 1-2
and catcher's interference base is
loaded nobody out no score bottom of the
first inning here's louis vincent
2-1 brinson hammers one right field
going back drury still going back
looking up
out of here a grand slam for louis
brinson
it's his fourth home run of the season
and the marlins have a four-nothing lead
in the first
fastball center cut thigh high drives it
out to right
four nothing marlins here in the first
we always say the guy who's hitting
fourth is
cleaning up but he just did
and jd lines one into center field for a
base hit
around second bias he'll go on to third
as sierra gets it in
so jd davis does take advantage with the
positive count
snaps his own for 12 stretch as the mets
have runners on first and third nobody
out and now dominic smith will bat
that gets away here comes baez from
third and he will score the first med
run of the day two down dave is still at
second and now the batter will be
brandon drury
you're one pitch drury lines toward left
that's a base hit
around third davis will score drury
heads towards second base
as brinson fires it in the throw is
close and it is not in time drury diving
in
has an rbi double the vents have gotten
two back here in the second and brandon
drury continues to be red hot
and sierra pops one up who wants it
javi does one out
and there's strike three called so
mcgill makes quick work of lizardo
with chip from still at first he hasn't
made any kind of move now he's running
the pitch low and away swung and missed
first strike three
alonso struck out his first time up
and alonzo rifles one deep left field
looking up as princeton it's out of here
peter lonzo with a line drive home run
number 24 for pete and it gets the mets
to win
in one run it's now four to three what a
bullet it doesn't matter if he gets him
in the air or line drives if he covers a
baseball
because of his strength usually is going
to end up over the wall
javi baez is up
he swings at a pitch out of the strike
zone and gross went to aguilar and his
throw on target to lizardo
and bias hurts himself on his way to
first base
assistant athletic trainer comes out so
bae is playing in his third game as a
match it looked like he was trying to
avoid luzardo as he hit the bag there
and took a bad step
and aguilar way off the plate away off
the base throws it over
he's in a great place right here but
watch where he tries to go right there
see him grabbing at that left ankle
that's that's the
place that he was having the problem in
chicago that ankle and heel on his left
foot well javi bias is going to try and
keep going looks like he reinjured that
ankle and heel it looks like he
exacerbated it
on that stumble into first base but he's
going to try and keep going
brinson at first after the one out
single issan diaz batting
who too is hit toward the gap in right
center field this will be extra bases
brinson flying around second heading
toward
third he's gonna get the green light
diaz will stop at second with an rbi
double five three marlins here in the
third
[Applause]
so one out base runner now mcgill will
come up to bunt and pushes the buns
there aguilar drops it and recovers it
quick enough to get the out and mcgill
is holding his left glute as he goes to
first base
i don't know what that's all about that
bear is watching
tyler mcgill appears to be a-okay after
that odd run to first base
jazz chisholm pops one up in the left
field has a little carry to it but dom
smith should have plenty of room
and that retires the side first one two
three inning for tyler freeway mcgill
0-2 pitch that's that slider we've come
to know and love
strikeout number one
ground ball left side isan plays it off
to the side spins and throws and gets
nimo
so that'll get alonzo to the plate as a
tying run which is just the way the mets
want him
pete's already homered once tonight that
came in the third he had an infield into
the fifth so he's two for three
here's the one-two pitch and it is hit
in the air
shallow right field playable for brian
de la cruz
it was a fastball that ran inside alonso
hit it off his fists
and the inning is over
love to see it as jeff mcneal sends one
out toward
left center field brinson moving back
and he'll make the play
and baez rolls over the slider tough
play for
diaz the bare hand too late and baez
despite running on that bad heel
able to sprint down to first on that
slow roller to beat it out for an
infield hit
so two out is left to dom smith tying
run at the plate in a 5-3 game dom's
over three tonight
and he pulls one on the ground through
the hole in the right field of base in
bias around second
he'll try to go first to third the throw
coming in is cut off
and the mets have runners at the corners
with two down and now drury will bat
with the tying run now in scoring
position and the potential lead run at
first base
floor o'deals and a ground ball too
short back handed by amiga goes the
short way and flouro gets out of the
mess
miggy out toward left center field this
is going to
get down and one hop the wall it's gonna
stay out there and miggy's on his way to
third
racing in with a triple
so now they're on the corners with
nobody out for lewis brinson
to third baez will go to first low pro
gets away from
alonso aguilar goes to third brentson to
second a run scored on the play
six to three five rbis tonight for
brinson
and that's line caught by bias and
everybody else
able to get back here's sierra now base
has loaded two outs
and sierra bounces one to mcneil and
that retires the side
and michael gets a slider and pulls it
down the line and that will go into the
corner for extra bases
it rattles around for de la cruz and
conforto pulls in at second base with a
lead-off double and the mets have
something going in the ninth
so that leaves the mets down to their
final out with jeff mcneal coming up
oh and one to mcneal and jeff takes one
the other way but right at diaz for the
last out of the game
vets have now lost four of their last
five as they're beaten tonight by the
marlins 6-3
you